Let's get to audience questions for the week
one, that in many forms, has been on a lot
of people's
mind, which I am sort of consolidating into.
One question is, Is this the start of a new
global
recession?
And the answer is maybe we don't know.
And as I've told you before, economists and
people in
general are very, very bad predicting the
economy in general.
Here's what we do know, and here are
a few thoughts on this.
Number one, the system we have has booms and
busts that goes back a very long time.
So every year that we don't have a bus we
don't have a downturn, we are a year closer
to the next
downturn.
I've been saying this since why 14­something
like that on the program there were people
predicting it would be, in 2016, there were
people predicting it would be in 2017.
I've never predicted exactly what it would
be.
I've said at some point there is going to
be a down
turn right now, we find ourselves in this
very precarious situation with multiple record
downturns
03/13/20 Page 12 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
and then erratic sort of partial recoveries
in the stock market, the stock market is not
the economy
but certainly when you were looking at that
is multiple thousand point swings in a single
day, one
way or the other, that is a sign that we have
a very fragile situation.
Number two, the virus stuff, of
course.
And what you're now seeing that I think is
actually going to lead to a positive conversation
in a
sense, in the middle of really bad things
going on, people losing money, out of the
retirement
accounts, people getting sick with the virus
oil prices all over the place Trump?
Trying to frame this
battle around oil prices as good for Americans.
Because it'll make gas cheaper.
Personally, I would rather not lose 15% in
two weeks out of my retirement account, then
20 cents
per gallon of gas.
Maybe that's 'cause I don't drive around that
much.
For some people maybe the
gas prices are more impactful everybody's
situation is different, but this if we are
seeing the
beginning of a global recession, what's really
important to understand is that while it may
have been
triggered by a combination of the virus causing
fears, and panic selling, which then leads
to a
companies downward revising profit estimates,
which makes more selling happen, which drops
the
stock market more, which eliminates a lot
of money and liquidity that could be available
for
businesses to expand.
And it causes the self­fulfilling prophecy.
So the virus profit all this stuff is
tied in, that may indeed be what we consider
triggers.
What is going on right now or what may be
happening but it doesn't change the underlying
fragility of the system.
I spoke about this earlier
when you have an economy that has...
I don't remember off hand the number it's
like half of the US
population can't afford an unexpected 400
expense or maybe it was 40.
percent can afford a 100. it's
something like that, right?
That is a fundamentally fragile situation.
So when you have a President bragging about
wages, are
up 15% or whatever the case may be, that doesn't
change if cost of living is up that people
are living
on the edge people are living paycheck to
paycheck.
When you have a tax reform plan done, were
the lions share of the tax savings?
Go to people who are already fine and have
no real need to spend
any more money to the very, very rich rather
than the lions share of the dollars going
to people who
actually are depending on their earned income
and wages, to fund their life styles, which
are not
extravagant.
By the way, you have a fragile situation,
you have the wealthy accumulating more at
the same time that you have people who are
living paycheck to paycheck.
Rarely any better off, that's an inherently
fragile situation.
So of course, when you have something like
the virus stock market crash companies saying,
We
don't think we're gonna make as much this
year.
As we thought, so we're gonna revise our estimates
downward that crashes the stock price.
We might have to lay people off, then those
employees,
without a job, I can't go out and buy things
in.
It is a self­perpetuating feedback loop.
Okay, so if this is the beginning of the global
recession maybe the virus is making it happening
a
year sooner than it otherwise would, or two
years sooner, or whatever.
The fundamental fragility of this economic
system that we have, which is a less regulated
form of
03/13/20 Page 13 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
capitalism, than some of the Northern European
countries is the way I would describe what
we have
in the United States that has not changed.
And it's always a matter of, Well, when is
the next hold
back, going to happen and what will trigger
it rather than have we really re­organized
the economy
to prevent this from happening at all.
Have we for example used a higher marginal
tax rate on the
very rich to raise the standard of living
for the greatest number of people so that,
maybe instead of
half the country being unable to afford an
unexpected 400 expense you reduce that to
only 10% of
the country is unable to afford an unexpected
50 expense that strengthens the economy significantly
rich people having more money in their bank
account that they're not planning to spend
anyway
does not strengthen the economy at the broad
level.
That is one thing that is very quickly being
exposed here.
This doesn't minimize the virus, the reality
of the virus, this doesn't minimize any of
the other things, the oil prices all of this
other stuff, but that is what I think we should
be focusing
on, which is, if it is the start of the new
global recession it was merely a matter of
time, and until the
system is changed to be less fragile and to
have fewer people living precariously, on
the edge of
being able to afford their not extravagant
lifestyles.
We're always just another year or two, or
a few
years from the exact same thing happening.
It's a feature of the system, not a bug.
And more and
more economists seem to understand this.